sky news understands that the uk plans
to set some
actually really tough new targets to
reduce emissions the government is set
to announce a pledge to cut carbon
emissions by
78 percent by 2035 it's only 14 years
compared to 1990 levels it's
really a big target how can we do it
well let's talk to the chief executive
of the national grid
john pettigrew really good to see you
this morning um
what do you make of this bold new target
do you think it's achievable
i think it's it's really good news
actually that the government has set
a you know a significantly massive i
think ambition
of 78 reduction by 2035 and it is
achievable
um you know what we've seen over the
last uh 18 months i think
is a lot of alignment not just in the uk
but around the world around big
ambitious targets
what's needed now of course is we need
to bring everybody together
and get the right policies and the right
frameworks so the investment can be made
to deliver on these targets
and of course one of the things we're
doing today is launching our green light
signal
which is really about engaging the whole
of the country and they can how they can
contribute
to to net zero and make their
contribution really tell
yeah i i will talk about that in just a
moment but where are we in terms of the
sort of the breakdown
of of uk power usage in terms of how
green we actually are at the moment
you know one of the things that we found
actually in our research is people don't
realize that how much progress has been
made so if you look at 2020 for example
what some of our research showed that
most people think only about 10 percent
by electricity comes from renewables
but actually in 2020 55
of all the electricity that we had in
the uk came from zero carbon generation
so if you compare that with just five
years ago for example so five years ago
about 25 percent of our electricity in
the uk came from coal
last year it was just 1.6 so there's
been huge progress
actually over the last five years and
that progress will continue
uh particularly now we've seen the
ambitious targets of the government set
yeah well in terms of getting the public
on board which is really important in
all this i think there's a much more
awareness now you've launched this light
bulb
i've i've got one here and of course it
looks just like a light bulb
but but how does it work how do you
actually let people know
if the energy they're using is green or
not
yeah so let's give you the background to
why we're launching uh the green light
signal
uh we did some consumer research and
what we found was that
we were looking to see how people how
much they understood what knowledge they
had about clean energy
in its role towards net zero and what we
found was about 38 percent of people
felt a sense of hopelessness actually
that around climate change and the
reason
for that was they didn't have the
information on the progress that's been
made
and the steps that are being taken and
also what we found was the
as a positive sign 70 of people felt
that they could individually make a
contribution
and actually more than half people said
they would feel really positive
if they had more information so the
campaign that we're launching today with
the light bulb
is really about raising awareness it's
about giving people data and information
so they can make informed choices so the
light bulb very simply you can
screw it into your desktop lamp and
when the carbon intensity of electricity
in the uk
is very low then actually it will come
on and it'll be green
and it will send you a message that
basically says it's a good time to use
electricity
rather than at other times the day
because actually it's the greenest time
of the day so
you know we're not expecting everybody
to go and buy a light bulb but
actually what it does it gives people
information so they can make informed
choices so they may decide to shift when
they use their washing machine for
example from one time of the day
to when the light bulb is green and the
carbon intensity is really low oh that's
really interesting then because i've
read all
i read all the bumps that came with it
this morning i didn't quite get that
aspect of it i have to be honest
so it is in effect a timer that says you
know if
you if you use your power now if you
turn the washing machine on or
as you say or or whatever then now is a
greener time to do it
yes if you look on average across the
the day in the uk so i think
typically today i think i've just had a
look actually on our website and
the carbon intensity today is around
about 270 grams
per kilowatt hour so 270 grams of carbon
emitted
every kilowatt hour the the light bulb
will indicate that
in your region if electricity is being
produced by green sources
and actually the carbon emitted is less
than about 150 grams
then actually it's a good time to use it
so the light bulb will come on and just
encourage you to do something you know
change your behavior slightly
as i said move the time you use washing
machine
and if you look across the country
obviously we've got different generation
in different places
and therefore at different times of the
day it will be greener than other times
today so we're just encouraging people
to take some action and as i said our
research showed that people want to take
action they want to be part of the
journey to climate change
it's quite a big challenge and it's
quite hard for them to get their heads
around so
i think for all of us it's quite hard to
get our heads around so this is just an
opportunity for people to engage
and actually make informed choices yeah
it's quite interesting i have to say
john pettigrew good to talk to you this
morning thank you